Is there a test to find out if you have leaky gut?
There is.
There's a test to find out because there's actually three different levels of, quote, quote,
the leaky gut.
So leaky gut is typically thought of as damage to the cellular border of the gut, the epithelial
layer of the gut.
And damage to the what are called the tight junctions, tight junctions, separate.
And now you are allowing things to be absorbed into your bloodstream that should have never
been allowed to be absorbed through your bloodstream.
And then you get this immune reaction to that thing because it's not just down to it
to be no acid, you're getting a larger peptide section of a protein.
And that's not ever supposed to be in your bloodstream, and your immune system can react
to it.
And you can develop antibodies against those things.
And now you got circulated antibodies in the tissues and in the lumen of the gut and every
time you eat that food or whatever, again, you have this immune reaction to that peptide
and then you have this inflammation that takes place.
That's what a food allergy, quote, sensitivity, quote, is all about.
And then that's just a downward spiral of inflammation of the gut that causes more damage to the epithelial
cellular and more openings of different tight junctions.
And then you got even, it just continues to worsen.
Now there's other levels to leaky gut as well.
You could actually have damage to the cells themselves where there's opportunity for things
to pass right through the cell in into circulation.
That's like the next step of damage to leaky gut.
And then there's a third level damage to leaky gut where you actually have lipopolysaccharides
being produced because of bacterial overgrowth.
Grammetic and bacteria have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membranes and when that becomes
when that dies, it becomes liberated lipopolysaccharides can then circulate through your bloodstream and
you can measure those.
So if you have elevated lipopolysaccharides, that means you have even worse damage leaky gut
because it becomes more of a problem because lipopolysaccharides directly damage the blood
brain barrier.
So they damage the astrocytes that make up the blood brain barrier and now you have the leaky
brain and that is a term.
So you actually have a damaged blood brain barrier and you have things getting into the brain
that should not get into the brain and now you got inflammation in the brain and when
you have inflammation in the brain, you can damage microglial cells which are the immune
cells in the brain and then they can become what are called primed damaged microglial cells
and they can stay in the M1 state and just spew out inflammation and cause this cascade
of problems that leads to dementia and forgetfulness and Parkinson's and antibody production
to neural tissue which is another cascade of problems where we get Alzheimer's and damage
to mileage.
She sells in demyelinated diseases and all sorts of neural issues.
So yes, dealing with the gut which goes back to that chronic constipation type issue, you
ignore things at your own risk, don't ignore things.
So when you have symptoms, symptoms are there to tell you that something is wrong that
you need to deal with it.
So make sure you don't just, that's the problem with practicing medicine the way medicine
is practiced these days.
You have a symptom that's take this drug, you have a symptom, you know, we can also practice
natural medicine that way, you have a symptom just take this, this nutrient that will maybe
make the symptom go away but not deal with the cause.
If the more you don't deal with cause, the more you suffer the consequences thereof.
So with anything in your life, you don't, you always want to try to get to cause or as close
to it as possible in order to actually solve the problem.
So the test for leaky gut, I think there are several companies that now have adopted the
same test it is for leaky gut as Syrex but Syrex has the array too which would be the test
for leaky gut, the test for all three levels of leaky gut and it's a blood test.